thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a deadly
wild ride with Stevo comedy fans Rejoice
we've got the host of kill Tony Tony
Hinchcliffe yeah dude this one's really
really deep into the comedy scene and
how it's moved from LA to Austin Texas
of course Rogan and Tony hinchcliff are
out there with a bunch of other
world-class Comics so this one's
particularly juicy and speaking of
Comedy I'm on my bucket list tour in
Charleston South Carolina right now but
these are the last dates of my bucket
list tour I'm actually taping my special
in multiple cities Albuquerque Little
Rock Arkansas Alabama to name a few
um and I'm bringing it International
Australia you've been begging for The
Bucket List tour and it's coming your
way
more on that later but this episode is
brought to you by athletic greens thank
God because that's what keeps me so
healthy and fit it fills in all the gaps
in my diet their product ag1 is the most
comprehensive convenient daily nutrition
you pour it into a pint of water in the
morning to get yourself hydrated it's
loaded with 75 different vitamins
minerals Whole Foods sourced superfoods
adaptogens probiotics it's got it all
baby and it's delicious it helps with
your gut health with your cognitive
abilities and it just fills in the gaps
in your diet if you're not getting all
of your nutrition don't worry about it
it's all in ag1 plus if you go to
athleticgreens.com Stevo they're going
to give you five free travel packs with
all of your daily nutrition in there
plus an entire year's supply of immune
bursting vitamin D that is only if you
go to athletic greens.com Devo you're
going to get all of that with your first
order so jump on it baby
athleticgreens.com Stevo and let's get
into it
ladies and gentlemen Tony Hinchcliffe
yeah dude hell yeah what's up we are in
Austin Texas Yep this van was driven all
the way from Los Angeles to Austin Texas
I've made that drive yeah it's a wild
one yeah dude it's nothing between
Phoenix in here pretty much but yeah El
Paso is the only you don't want to stop
there you don't I stopped there at an
Olive Garden for some reason I'm like
this will be a good idea
and and it like it wasn't it wasn't I'm
like the Olive Garden's safe it's a
corporate thing you know you're not
going to get food poisoning in an Olive
Garden you'll be for that I didn't get
food poisoning but it was it was just a
nightmare
how long have you been in Austin about
two years now two years wow and I was in
LA for 16 years and I came out here and
got hooked man yeah whole different ball
game
we were at your show the other night and
you were you and the one dude were
ripping on each other yeah pretty quick
really really impressive well what I'm
impressed with is because like uh you
know I read that you grew up in
Youngstown Ohio and like that was like
kind of like a defense mechanism yeah so
like when you go places by default are
you constantly doing that to people no I
don't do it I have a such an incredible
amount of outlets for it
um that being one every Monday I have
David Lucas there to go back and forth
with so it's like I'm like a power
lifter that gets to go to the gym you
know if he doesn't go to the gym he's
probably out there breaking windows and
throwing [ __ ] and you know road rage
to be clear what what these guys are
doing what Tony's doing with this like
improv insult comedies so it's it's
indicative of such intelligence you
can't become like super intelligent as a
defense mechanism
sure you can you could be [ __ ]
playing chess
if you grew up in a household where like
your only child and you're just like a
chest psycho I don't know I'm just
saying I was wildly impressed well I was
wildly impressed too well what's crazy
if I could if I could share this with
you is that we've been doing this show
forever we're coming up on our 10-year
anniversary of kill Tony right and David
has been a regular on it I think for
three or four years so that's 52 new
minutes
a year if we're if we don't take him on
the road with us some special Friday
Saturday tapings and big theaters and
stuff so that's even more than 52
minutes a year which means that we're
roasting each other because that
normally lasts
will say you know at least five minutes
at minimum five minutes we go back and
forth every week completely improvised
and it's all new and it's always new
it's obviously framed in the same you
know thing he makes fun of me for being
feminine or gay or whatever his angle is
at that point and how you make fun of
him for being you know big and black I'm
a pasty white guy he's a black guy it's
I think it's something you know this
part's corny but I think it's something
that should be more seen and under you
know like put out there because it's
it's you know it's what's cool about
America and what but what I wanted to
say is that what's wild about what David
and I are doing is we feel like we're
hitting a crazy stride like we now are
doing this dance where it's like writing
in public yeah and it's we're trying to
obviously get a half but we're trying to
get a laugh off of what the other person
said so it's kind of like Freestyle
rapping sure it's just wild where do
what's crazy is that we're hitting a
stride where we're like was that [ __ ]
was that 30 better than last week when
which we said was our best one you know
when we get up to that green room we do
a little like recap like we [ __ ] did
that [ __ ] tonight you know what I mean
you can feel it so did he move out here
yep just to get roasted by you well yeah
all the regulars that we had in La moved
out here and uh it it's an honor and a
wild thing even Michael Lair who you saw
get Hall of Fame inducted
uh
um was the first to move here with
debilitating ALS Advanced you know PLS
ALS the whole works and he puts it all
together he gets the writing the rest
the everything to be able to do a minute
every week and he loves it you know yeah
William Montgomery another one got out
here and found sobriety which is crazy
because he was going down a wild wild
Road and even you would be like yes
whoa but uh and he's absolutely thriving
there's a weird thing happening here in
Austin where you know I I'm trying to
I've been trying to put my finger on it
because I'm like why do I love this
place when I go on the road now you know
how you miss LA and when the planes when
you see the big buildings out your right
side you know like oh here we go we're a
few minutes away from L.A it's home and
I lived out for 16 17 18 years and and
uh
and now I get that feeling here like
much much more and because it I don't
know there's something about the lack of
like
la like Billboards stars on a sidewalk
like all of these things that are like
well it's not as fake right out here
exactly that's one thing yeah big time
that's an easy way of putting putting it
but I'm talking about like the
psychological effects of living in La I
can see like in Neons you know what I
mean like it's literally like what are
you living in Instagram yeah yeah
there's all these people that aren't
real like [ __ ] smoking uh there is
some really hot chicks out in Austin
I'd even say there's hotter chicks in
Austin than there is in La yeah
yeah it's it's wild out here I mean it's
absolutely insane there is kind of a
look that they all have that you know
gets a little bit tricky if they live
here too long that you're talking about
leg tat weird leg tattoos that look like
you know they were like Sailors at one
point in their lives or something they
love the bangs out here that's a thing
yeah they're at some point they're just
like looking at how does the cost of
living compare
night and day I mean a lot cheaper here
a lot cheaper here and there's a lot
more economy here it's just booming so
like people
you know one of the perks of being at
the comedy store for so long and
starting there and working up there is
that you get people from different
places visiting so you get a different
vibe it's not just La it's not like
performing in like Silver Lake or Echo
Park or somewhere that's like off the
beaten path and just locals The Comedy
Store gives you a wide variety of
different types of humans and now we're
getting that here people are traveling
here all the time you know uh it's
becoming like an open destination
whereas people that use I feel like
people that used to visit LA and New
York are like uh now might not be the
time they might get it back soon but I
don't think Now's the Time to Go
Vacation at this place to go listen to
music and nightlife there's it's really
crazy here the music here is the
craziest part I wish I could have
dragged you out to where we ended up on
Monday night because what time do you go
to sleep now I'm
generally up pretty late but I
um don't really
go out in public too much right right
but you would love this because and
another thing about Austin is they're
cool with famous people if you're at a
good place you know what I mean like
everybody's very chill like it's like oh
blah blah blah blah they live here you
know
um but this but there's music places
here I won't even shout them out because
I don't want it to get too packed but
there's places here we're literally
musicians go to see their musicians
favorite musician and it's
like you know encapsulated in rooms like
this like there's just three musicians
in a corner yeah we had the chance
Curtis was going to take us yeah he was
a cool guy yeah we uh he was he was
thrilled and he's like there'd be like
you know people come up and there's four
guitars playing at the same time and
just and it's like the best guitarist in
the world exactly and they're doing
their best stuff and they're laughing
they're doing kind of like what I was
talking about with David Lucas they're
like [ __ ] did we just [ __ ] do that
you know what I mean you can see it live
and the band that you have coming up
before you guys they they Improv
for that first 15 minutes oh yeah you
guys I mean they're incredible they're
all professional musicians way
overqualified to be part of it but they
know what they're doing you know what I
mean like they're excited to be part of
something that is raw and sort of rock
and roll
comedy they can feel it too
um when when you moved out here
did
the caliber of comedians in the bucket
like go down no not at all
um I guess the caliber of comedians
you're talking about the people that go
on Showtime yeah the people who get on
stage and do the one minute set use
amateurs it's interesting because I
thought that it was going to go down
but
what ends up happening is the type of
person that moves to Austin for comedy
is more prepared they're more
um I find them to be more ready to be on
a show like kill Tony where someone
might go to start in La you know what I
mean and some people are starting here
too but the type of people that know to
move to Austin instead of what we were
all told was that your two options the
first the last 40 years which is LA and
New York
um
I think it I think it brings a different
type of more uh intellectual ready
prepared type of someone that knows they
have to do some serious work
um with that said there's still you know
horrible comedians that get pulled out
of the bucket but yeah I think one guy
from Iowa wasn't too good yeah he was
from Idaho Idaho you know what it is I
think it's easier to be crazy in La you
blend in more so anybody can sign up
there so it'd be you know 160 sign ups
anything can possibly happen right and
we had a lot of bad bucket pulls back
then well there's a lot of mental
illness in la oh yeah and they find
their way on stage sometimes and you
also had like Bonafide like breakout
Stars huge
speaking of huge I wonder how huge your
anxiety is about Christmas gift giving
this year are you just gonna go ahead
and do the old boring gift card thing or
are you gonna do something awesome
original
with
hellotushy.com what's hellertushy.com
it's my favorite sponsor we've ever had
on this podcast they make bidets that
just blast your butthole with a
refreshing stream of water it's just
like power cleaning your poop shoot and
it is the best feeling man to just walk
away from taking a dump knowing that
you're totally clean and it's the best
gift that you can give somebody man it's
fun it's funny it's useful it's
practical it's techy but it's affordable
I'm telling you man
hellotushy.com plus if you go to
hellotushy.com
Stevo then not only did you get 10 off
your order you also get free shipping
because they love the listeners of the
Wild Ride podcast and you've probably
heard me say this before
Hello tushy.com is my favorite sponsor
of this podcast because these bidets are
my favorite product I've ever told you
guys about if you haven't tried it yet
man
do your butthole a favor do your loved
ones buttholes a favor go to
hellertushy.com
Stevo enjoy 10 off your order plus free
shipping now let's talk about these huge
Stars
huge preacher Lawson uh so many of them
I mean all the regulars are the girl
that uh
ended up going on Rogan
um Ali mikovsky yeah yeah I mean she
came from Kill Tony yeah
like every week she was on kill Tony yep
she would do a new minute every week and
so and Kim Congdon and Sarah weinshank
and you know William David Michael Lair
wow
um William Montgomery
and
yeah I'm missing a couple the the guy
that you guys
I mean because Tom Segura was their last
and he was like yeah if you want to come
on the road with me like it just happens
like that
it happened I don't know that Tom Segura
said you want to come on the road with
me weren't they like let's talk about
dates and he's like yeah December he did
he booked William Montgomery for the
first week of December right yeah that
guy's just I mean did that happen to
that guy often or is that the first time
not exactly the first time no I take him
on the road with me Duncan Trussell
takes some on the road with him but yes
you are correct you're a theory that
that is going to be a huge break for him
I'm positive of it those two are going
to absolutely fall in love once Tom
realizes that Williams like common sense
and can chill and just be cool like it's
it's gonna be game over because William
what I told Tom afterwards as I go when
you when he gets brought out at whatever
venue you're taking him to
listen when his name gets set at the pop
that the crowd will have at your show
because he's you know these guys are out
there doing a new minute every week it's
it doesn't seem like much on the surface
but when you realize a special if you
get someone to sit through a special
that's what someone comes out with that
once every few years that's just
54 minutes you know what I mean now that
we're like looking at them at these
people that are watching a minute every
week and the interview so again it only
takes a month of appearance this is a
regular on kill Tony to have a special's
worth of time of connection with these
people they know about your real life so
not only is he up doing a minute every
week as a stand-up comedian in front of
these people he's also doing a six
minute podcast essentially about his
life I'm asking him questions and and
William's a little bit of a weird
example because he's so bizarre on stage
and is so goofy but the reading from the
have you ever encouraged them to not oh
yeah totally no yeah oh yeah we broke
him of that he used to do that during
his actual stand-up sets now when he's
doing a minute we'll let him get away
with it he's not gonna do that on
sagura's opening no chance no no notes
no chance in hell yeah we broke him of
that it was a very very bad habit of his
there were times where we're like no
more notes because sometimes he had it
on a big thing and he would just like
literally stare at it while reading the
jokes while doing sold out shows with us
and we're like nah dude you gotta it's
cool and all but he was he would like
glance up for a second and then go right
back to it and it was a treacherous
course it took him months and months and
months he went from that to a smaller
piece of paper to the paper on the stool
glancing at the stool glancing at the
stool we would bust his balls William we
see you glancing at the stool between
every joke then it was on his phone and
then it wasn't and now he can you know
go out there and have a blast for 20
minutes in a giant theater in a sold out
comedy club in an arena he could do
anything you're used to going on doing
theaters and in larger venues like two
three thousand cap and then on your own
and then and then Rogan takes you on the
road to do an arena or whatever or like
what's the biggest you've done and then
when you went out on stage for the first
time for like 19 000 people were you
just like
I mean was it kind of like being a
newcomer again or were you more pumped
when you went out there was like whoa
this is [ __ ] crazy well uh
the biggest one they're all about the
same size it's all summer between like I
don't know 15 and 20 000 and we've done
a ton of them so to give anyone like
extra credit would be like the first one
you did when you went from that jump
from like two the first yeah the first
one is interesting because if you you're
doing an arena you want to be in the
middle in the round which is something
that we really just started doing a
couple years ago
um and uh but in the beginning the first
few Arenas we were on the Far Far Side
like a music show right
um and it's just totally different
being in the round it's like being in a
comedy club it's like being in like a
perfect
comedy thing you're like in an orb of
energy and they're everywhere so you're
just turning around and you know moving
around a little bit and the big cameras
that they have there follow you so that
people in the arena Arena are looking up
at this thing and glancing down so it
like is all very connective and it works
incredibly well uh whereas being on the
end of an arena is sort of uh you have
to there's Acoustics issues you're not
exactly sure what the pacing is and the
timing is and there's only one front row
instead of four front rows you know what
I mean so
um
but now we have it figured out you know
it's it's unbelievable there's nothing
like it and it's it's a it's like uh
it's like
doing the in the round Arenas and then
going back and doing my own like
headlining shows is like going from
flying private to being Southwest yeah
yeah boarding Group G yeah
yeah it's crazy do you find that with
Arenas that like
you're more struggling with the
disruptiveness in the audience or less
no I find it to be less the most
disruptive thing to me is a room where
there's you know a hundred people
squeezing in like sardines and they get
you at just the right time like it
doesn't really fly in arenas someone
would have to go ballistic to be uh
disruptive to the show they'd have to
literally scream and other people would
be like sit down you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know what I mean like yeah to carry that
because the speakers are so strong it's
a very present experience much more than
I ever would have expected and luckily
you know Rogan has a very smart audience
these people are listening to him
talking with scientists and whatnot for
hours every day they're a lot better
listeners than you would expect if you
didn't know like people might assume
that oh he's the UFC guy he's the
Fairfax their guy but like he's not
filling up Arenas because of his
commentary or right um
uh Fear Factor that's a fair point and
so it's a really great crowd and man
they're also there they're also you know
they love
Free Speech if you want to call it that
which you know they're hoping that they
get to see some exciting stuff you know
the phones are all locked up for those
so they already know like like what's
going on which I think every place I
think that's how restaurants and bars
and stuff should be now too it's
probably the future in 10 years yeah
like it's it's it's really interesting
you say that because
um I think that when people meet me
there's a tendency to think oh wow you
know you're not like the
Maniac crazy guy you're actually like a
thoughtful like seemingly intelligent
guy I didn't expect that and then like
my crowd
you probably have like a bird Chrysler
crowd like similar Drinkers and yeah
Partiers and yeah my my crowd like I'm
sober my crowd drinks more than anybody
yeah like we hear it all the time that
like that uh whatever venue I'm at like
broke their record for selling booze yep
and then we have bits in the in the show
where like there's needles involved for
like vasectomies and so people pass out
so the drinking and the needles like we
get you know two or three people
dropping out a show I don't even know
that it's got anything to do with the
the drinking people just pass out at my
show
we give them a free bottle of hot sauce
that they pass out really yeah well I do
I mean you know it's always during a
certain bit but yeah I mean I can't like
I can't wait for you to see the new hour
dude I can't wait too that's what's
crazy is that you know
we just get to keep getting better at
stuff dude so whatever the new stuff is
is you know yeah it's crazy I always
feel like oh man like uh I'm ready and
then
a few more years down the road looking
back on it it's like oof yeah yeah no
it's funny it's like even like
you know I record a lot almost yeah like
99 of all my sets and um on video or
just audio both and uh
and it's funny because uh you know when
you're trying to even shoot a special or
something like that if you have if you
do and you have a show the next week and
obviously you're still you know you
don't have a might not have a brand
whatever new material to fill so you do
the same joke again and you accidentally
add a new tag kills it you're like wait
what the hell how's this possible Right
it didn't happen the last 10 weeks when
I was getting ready for this thing and
one week later right yes the girl was
just telling us about all these shows
that he's doing after having taped the
special and I'm like aren't just I'm
thinking aren't you terrified that
you're gonna develop some genius new
thing and you already taped it
oof are you constantly but you're not
really constantly adding I'm dead it's a
try I mean you're cutting so absolutely
coming up with new stuff like I mean
it's a a super gradual Evolution but
like these little tiny things are
constantly happening and how you say
something and what you take out
especially you know from one show to the
next like I mean not every show is gonna
they're gonna have a change but you know
I'm not gonna go for a week without
there being
something that's important to me
yeah it's impossible to do shows for a
week and not
have something or you're like man so to
be married to a to a special and
continue to do the show after
that that would freak me out
yeah how do you deal with hecklers
because I feel like you would almost be
stoked on hecklers because you can
that's your like Forte of just yeah and
then do you kick them out after it all
depends on exactly the situation it's
all they all get handled on a
case-by-case basis and how annoying and
what their attitude is and how drunk
they are and it's a it's it's a
I don't even know how to describe it I
mean they have to be
obviously
annoying to the audience I have to get
they have to make sure that it's clear
that yeah I'm the good guy you know what
I mean because I definitely
early on in my career there were times
where I would kick people out and and
just mishandle the situations completely
trying to have an original take on a
Heckler that you go so far over the line
that you know yeah
I once uh
I once called that
Jimmy Kimmel's Aunt the c word
yeah but I didn't know it was Jimmy
Kimmel's aunt at the time and this is
like
13 years ago like I'm like a couple
years into stand up and
actually no it was like yeah it was like
10 years ago 11 years ago
but I had no idea and it you know at the
time
it was still a pretty big deal if you
were going to get on Jimmy Kim alive and
do stand up or whatever and
um there were these two old ladies
talking in the front row I'm waiting for
my spot all night it's like 1 30 in the
morning right
and I'm a brand new paid regular this is
how I know that it's 10 years ago or 11
years ago anyway uh and it's 1 30 and
they're talking and there's only eight
people in the room right there's these
two old white ladies there's two people
in the back middle that are like just
drunk and sobering up because they're at
The Comedy Store at 1 30 and they know
it's over at two and whatever and
there's like two more people back right
and whatever else there's like nobody
there but these two old white ladies in
the front just keep talking and at the
time I'm literally trying to exercise
the muscle of going through your set and
not acknowledging them I'm like trying
to work that muscle because I'm so bad
at it especially early on where I I
would over acknowledge everything what'd
you say over there I was looking for any
escape to not have to work on these
jokes right and I'm trying and I'm
trying I'm five minutes in I'm six
minutes in I'm like oh my God they're
still talking seven minutes in they're
still talking eight minutes in there's
liter they're literally 20 of the
audience so finally 10 minutes in I go
uh
oh what the hell are you two ladies
[ __ ] talking about I mean I've waited
all night up here for this
and you're a percentage of the audience
what the [ __ ] could possibly be going on
it's 10 min it's been 10 minutes you two
have been talking
and she says we're talking about whoever
is going on after you
and I took that as
we're just next you know what I mean
uh-huh but what she was actually saying
was is we're talking about the guy
that's going on after you Don Barris
because he's the warm-up guy for Jimmy
Kimmel and we've known him for decades
and we're close with him we're here to
see Don Barris is what okay she should
have said but instead I took it as
yeah right and so I just loaded up and
went berserk you [ __ ]
boom yeah and
people like you or the scum of the earth
that don't respect art and you're
Un-American and you're not a good person
and if this is how you're acting now I
can't imagine what your [ __ ] children
must think about you and their
children's children you're probably that
worst [ __ ] grandma you wrinkly bag of
[ __ ] nothing Burger dough I mean I
went crazy for the last five minutes I
spent 10 minutes ignoring her in five
minutes lighting her up she went the
next day and wrote letters
to the heads of CAA WME ABC I'm not even
kidding Jimmy Kimmel himself Jeff Ross
who you know is good friends with Jimmy
Kimmel and she knew that because somehow
she found out immediately probably but
however that I was working with him and
he's like what the hell did you do to
this lady that
she's writing letters to everybody
saying never work with him in all of
Show Business
wow she's literally like if any of you
ever work with this man you're asking
for a problem he is the devil incarnated
you ever run in the Jimmy Kimmel yep
that sounds like it might have been an
awkward encounter but let's face it
could it be any more Awkward than when
you're in bed with a girl and she finds
a bunch of disgusting Bush all over your
dong and your chest I mean come on it's
2022 boys it's time to clean up your act
with manscapes man you want to be sleek
and smooth and feel good about how you
look and come on manscaped it's what's
up these days all right and with their
Platinum package 4.0 they're giving you
the deal of a lifetime it's all of the
best stuff they've got from their best
selling performance package but this one
includes Ultra Premium body wash Ultra
Premium two in one shampoo conditioner
and Ultra Premium deodorant that's on
top of the lawnmower 4.0 and the weed
whacker all of the best stuff in one
package and if you go to manscaped.com
Stevo not only will you get 20 off your
order but free shipping as well I'm
telling you man it's another one of
these gifts that's fun and funny and
practical and affordable and man if it's
your dad your brother your husband I
mean
with the hair coming out of the nostrils
man it's time for that to end put the
manscaped Platinum package 4.0 under the
tree for these gentlemen laugh about it
have a good time and they will thank you
later so one more time it's
manscapes.com Devo for 20 off your order
plus free shipping now let's talk about
that encounter with Jimmy Kimmel
and you want to know what it was he was
actually judging uh uh roast battle one
of the televised seasons of roast battle
which uh you know I do I did I'm good at
and he was a judge with nightmare [ __ ]
and we're walking backstage you know
whatever blah blah blah we pass by each
other and he goes hey Tony inchcliffe
you're the guy to call my aunt
and what is what'd you say I go that was
you know I play you know I was just
honest I go I don't know how much she
told you but he goes I get it I get it
he he got it yeah yeah
yeah wow [ __ ] this but I knew I was
doomed the second he said that I'm like
oh my God there's even if I eviscerate
this person five jokes to zero this
guy's gonna go with [ __ ] Aunt Chippy
or whatever
he was judging you
like uh you were a contestant yeah yeah
where you make fun of each other back
and forth right silly [ __ ] back in the
day do you already know what you would
say to me if I talk [ __ ] to you would
you come over I mean what do we already
know like uh well I feel like now that
you said that in between when you said
that and now yeah he already has that's
when it happens I mean I didn't know
that the [ __ ] MythBusters had Down
syndrome over here you know what I'm
saying I was just curious how quickly it
happens like because I feel like you
know when I'm driving I'm just like this
[ __ ] and I come up with [ __ ] in my
head yeah like is that that's what I'm
asking if it's like by default and then
you go tape another episode of Adam
ruins everything so it just happens like
it happens like that huh I mean I don't
know I guess so with shoes like that you
must know what it's like I'm kidding I
don't know it doesn't even make sense I
was just so impressed with you guys
going back and forth at the show it was
just uh I was like [ __ ] man how do you
do that yeah it's a weird muscle you
know I was watching uh
my buddy sent me a clip of Rick Rubin
talking with Joe Rogan about different
rappers processes about how you know uh
Eminem writes everything down he writes
all day into a notebook tiny little
letters words every single thing he just
writes and Jay-Z writes nothing and this
person does that and this person does
that and
you know I mean that's pretty much it
it's just like we got good at not having
to write it down take what's given to
you you know Jay-Z would listen to a
beat and
not have any idea of what the song could
be and whatever and goes right on the
other side of a wall on the other side
of the glass and makes that background
beat a [ __ ] iconic hit that we all
know that everybody yells in the middle
of the night
just like it was meant to be yeah
um I mean of course I'm comparing me
calling David Lucas a fat black guy uh
to Jay-Z so I have to catch myself
sometimes though right now I think it's
uh it's completely fair to
you know it's all improv yeah it is it's
wild man and it's something that I get
to look forward to and you try to apply
topical things to it and like what's in
the news maybe you know I called him
Hershey Walker for the first time last
night Hershey or Monday night yeah
Hershey Walker for some reason it works
chocolate bar Herschel Walker just lost
his election oh did it did he lose I
think so yeah
David licker said how bad of a
politician do you have to be to go on a
runoff against Herschel Walker yeah it's
kind of funny you want to know an
interesting thing you guys might find it
uh cool is that after that roast was
David Lucas I realized that there was a
joke that I should have done and those
bother me that happens a lot where it's
like oh we did so good but I could have
done this yeah because remember how he
had the wings on the back of his shirt
and I and and I go that's gonna be a
rough takeoff I realized afterwards that
I should have said that's gonna be a
rough takeoff that's gonna be worse than
the takeoff the takeoff had the other
day when he took off like I could have
just like boom boom boom boom because
the rapper takeoff got shot
yeah it's a rougher takeoff than takeoff
had last week any version of it would
have been like
George Costanza he's like a jerk store
called and he's like [ __ ] dwelling on
it all day you know
um the uh that reminds me of the best
tweet I ever saw which was by
um
Jeff Ross when the magician was found uh
hanging dead of suicide in the Magic
Castle
and uh
and Jeff Frost tweeted the TMZ story
link just with the word
Abracadabra
oh he's the best I wrote his writing on
his show was the first any type of break
I ever had ever yeah I spent the first
four weeks in the writer's room eating
all the natures Valley granola bars from
the snack area because I literally
didn't have money for lunch there was a
period of time where everybody would
collect money and you know put your
money in an envelope for the lunch thing
and I was like no no I'm good this week
and I would go eat like two bananas and
four granola bars because I didn't want
anybody to know that I was completely
broke I mean totally a starving artist
yeah and I we were writing we had so
much fun and that reminds me of one of
the jokes that the great Sarah Tiana
wrote you know Sarah right I don't know
that I know she's amazing paid regular
at The Comedy Store Little Country Girl
and uh it was David copperfield's
birthday
so we were trying to figure out you know
we did this thing called burn days where
if it was your birthday that night in
the monologue he would pay tribute to
you by making fun of you and it was
anyway it was David copperfield's
birthday and the joke that Sarah Tiana
wrote was
happy
Happy Birthday to David Copperfield I
wanted to get you something but I
couldn't pick a card any card
that's good
yeah right kill Tony uh doesn't stream
live anymore not anymore no we you know
the it's so hard for a production like
that to uh with all the stuff that
happens in live shows
um to uh have the sound and the video
and everything as good as it can be so
we decided to just start running it
through a process and right
um so what's the the delay
two weeks two weeks yep wow yeah so
people aren't gonna see how much I
crashed it on there for two weeks that's
true man unless you put this out in two
weeks in which case it would have
happened yesterday it will happen yeah
about two weeks what day does it go up
two from yesterday so the 28th
about two from The 14th Century it'll be
a Monday night yeah okay
because Thanksgiving is Thursday the
24th
so yeah how about that
um that was
[ __ ] amazing by the way that was so
perfect it's it was it's just amazing I
mean it worked out on so many levels in
so many ways and your story is just
hilarious it's great that you get
to uh you know there's risk reward on a
show like that right you're like Jesus
what if something gets [ __ ] stuck in
my throat what if something gets in my
eye what if anything what if there's pee
on my pants what if my shoelace is
untied in any circumstance so many
things can go wrong and when it goes
[ __ ] great it's awesome
it's like uh
you think whoa
here I'm gonna I'm on kill Tony I'm
gonna get up and and do the uh like like
like somebody out of the bucket you know
but but I do this like
I better [ __ ] do good or this is
gonna be awful yeah yeah and it's cool
that you get that validation
um from Tom on top of you know what I
gave you about how you did the work man
you know what I mean so many people and
I even had this talk with Joe last night
in the Green Room of the show that we
did about how you went and did it you
know there's the old Trope of comedians
that are like oh someone's coming that's
already famous you know like yikes good
luck but man you really you really did
it and made the adjustments and you know
you didn't let your ego
do the stand-up comedy work you know
what I mean thanks so much man it's
that's hard to do it's hard to be that
self-aware and we see it all the time
even with people that get great
they all of a sudden kind of realize
they're great like it's like a
championship fighter right yeah when you
have that belt all of a sudden you get
invited to more of this and more of that
and life is this and you can get
comfortable and content and instead
you're out here [ __ ] driving a van
across the country doing spots doing
podcasts getting guests you know
thriving making huge appearances
creating your own body of work that you
don't have to give to
freaking whoever Warner Brothers or MGM
or whatever it all is and you know we
live in a very very fun time it's very
exciting it really really is man I I
remember when I started making YouTube
videos
I thought like oh this is embarrassing
yeah and like
it's funny dude I wasn't I've you know
I've written for the last whatever 10
Comedy Central roasts or whatever and I
remember when being on YouTube and
having a podcast where the insults on
somebody right a decade ago and now on
these things and for the last two or
three I got to watch it go all the way
to being the intro for somebody right
you know your next comedian from their
hit podcast
like crazy well it's crazy we go to Just
for Laughs and like we'll go see a show
at a theater beforehand it's I'm like
who are these guys like dude they're
YouTubers and they're [ __ ] selling
out yeah and then the video game people
um
when like the the comedy club or some
theater is like people playing video
games and it's completely sold out for
people coming to pay money to watch
people play video games that's insane I
just heard of this the other day I don't
believe it and they're making so much
money I guess that's what that's what
somebody told me I've always said that
like uh I think video games are are
responsible for like the decline of of
our nation yeah you know like just the
idea of just sitting there and just just
wasting your time playing video games
just becoming fat and and just lazy and
unmotivated but then now we're taking it
to another level people are actually
wasting their time watching other people
play video games it's unbelievable who
is that porn star that uh Adriana
chechnick or something she's a
I mean what do I know but uh no she's a
uh I guess she went from porn to
streaming video games and she was at
some award show she broke her back and I
mean she broke her back at the awards I
guess she fell and like she was in pain
or whatever but that's not normally how
porn stars get their back broken out
their back she threw her back out but
did they they were like you know when it
made the headlines it was like in famous
Twitter you know Adriana whatever I'm
like she's just not even known as a porn
star anymore she's just a a video game
streamer I wonder if she twitched when
she broke her back
but yeah I mean it's uh there's some
crazy money involved in that you know
it's insane and these chicks dress up
smoking hot and they play video games
and it's just yeah I mean T-Pain was
telling us that like uh he's making more
money playing video games on Twitch than
from music
wow isn't that crazy yeah
um so what's your touring like uh how
much are you touring on your own as a
headliner I've been I I've been doing it
yeah I've been going way too hard yeah
too hard yeah yeah yeah I think that's
the case with everybody after the
pandemic we just went ape [ __ ] yeah
everybody's just Tom's fried you're
fried I'm fried you're free you know
yeah everybody's fried yeah um so you
just got on the weekends yeah and yeah a
couple weeks ago I did a longer run and
it burnt me out so hard that I haven't
really caught up since then but now I'm
done I'm at the point to where I get to
call my shots and so like I have
December off except for Arlington Dallas
in the middle of December
um and that's a two and a half hour
drive so that's like really really easy
no airport in the Arlington where Gringo
poppy was filmed
wait is that where is that where that
was filmed is it the the Dallas Improv
Arlington I think so yeah that's where
Gringo poppy was found oh no tough act
to follow
[Laughter]
us on
oh man how do you know that how do you
know that was filmed there ah I was
fascinated by the end
I even know where the construction paper
came from
oh my gosh
I even know who cut it out
oh my God it's so funny yeah we all are
we're all very fascinated about it it
was fascinating yeah yeah I mean just
like I'm particularly close to that
because of the known for other things
coming into stand up like um
first special on Showtime you know and
then like uh putting out the second
special on on you know yeah on your own
35 minutes
[Applause]
oh my goodness
oh it's interesting it's like uh it's
like
death by a thousand self-inflicted paper
cuts or something yeah it's pretty
intense
um but yeah like so so I was
particularly you know
because like uh and I I don't know I
just I care a lot you know yeah you
still feel that way though because
people are always saying like
you really worked your ass off I uh
I found my stride in what I do and I'm
perfectly comfortable about it I don't
think uh you know no other comedians
[ __ ] jumping out of an airplane
jacking off
right and I'm not like claiming to be so
great you know that I think that's the
other problem there is that when you're
like that's the thing yeah yes oh yeah
dude I'm you know it's a study this is
this is yeah I mean it is a study of
there's something going on because we're
figuring out this internet thing right
we're figuring out social media and I
always lay low I'm weirdly like I don't
promote thing I just like to I'm just
not into it
but
um
I think the showy offy stuff is come to
an end those slow motion shots of
walking to the stage with a drink and
taking a sip and all that stuff it's
like people are ready for the jokes
right they are ready to go that's why
like my homie Ari shaffir special so
damn good yeah yeah
ridiculously good and this is a guy
that's just throwing punches the whole
time there's no no absorbing no taking
any you know time doing anything boom
boom boom boom yeah it was so wildly
impressed by Ari's juice special yep
yeah I opened for him I did a guest spot
on his show right before he filmed it
around the corner here and I was on the
other side of that wall in the green
room and I was hearing the Beats from
the audience just whoosh
the actual taping no just before the
taping when he was in like fighter shape
for it right right he was smashing this
little room and it sounded like the
[ __ ] walls were going to come down
and you know I'm just so happy for him
that's a that's a guy who you know they
tried to cancel for a joke and now is
thriving on his own there's like a real
right I feel like when you've been
wronged by the media and the internet uh
you know it makes you fight back with a
little bit more
strength well I had this idea
because I only knew him from the media
and then we we had him on the podcast a
couple weeks ago and he was cool as [ __ ]
yeah I mean like you know yeah he's a
little Mensch oh oh totally he's
literally my big brother one of the
nicest guys in the world
um and he's a big part of the reason why
I'm in that whole Rogan world to begin
with like he was the one that
recommended me when he started
headlining so much that he couldn't open
for Joe anymore Joe's like well who else
is coming up the ranks like who whatever
and already threw me right into the mix
and I've worked with Joe ever since then
and Ari was a tremendous tremendous help
when
uh when I made fun of the Asian kid that
went on before me back in May of 2021
right I remember that yeah and like that
completely clipped out of context and
made it seem like I was just attacking
some innocent kid that had no idea what
didn't what was going on didn't the kid
kind of get behind it like well he was
completely he was the only one behind it
he was he literally him and his friend
clipped it uh he legally recorded it
then clipped it and then sent it to uh
the Chinese media who actually leaked
that he had tweeted this
clip before he tweeted it
because he slept in or something they
like messed up the coordination this was
actually a and I'm not a big conspiracy
guy but I know what happened and it was
like a coordinated very interesting
attack that you know was the news for a
couple days I have a dirty stand-up show
where phones are locked up and they're
warned that there's dirty jokes and he
knows me he's open for me he's been on
keltoni got pulled out of the bucket
years ago and I helped him he got to
make out with a white trash girl that
show he had never kissed an American
Girl wow Crowd Goes Crazy everybody had
fun and uh he thought he would uh get
famous by being a victim
um and have you seen them since nope
haven't seen them haven't heard much
it's a shame
is there any lasting effect from that
like the opposite it was literally
everything got better any comedy fan
especially the ones that knew me before
that I mean knows what's going on there
in a stand-up comedy show there is no
like oh he made fun of comedian too bad
like what a joke I mean right you're a
comedian it'd be one thing if it was an
audience member but even then they're in
the audience at a comedy show like it's
so bizarre the problem I have with the
the media's handling of it is it's so
interesting to me that they if if they
know nothing about me and they see the
clip and they go to me and you type in
Tony Hinchcliffe literally the first
thing that popped up was American insult
Comedia yeah Tony Hinchcliffe was born
in Youngstown Ohio but literally the
first words right all right also the
second line is you open for Rogan and
and then they don't like wrote you know
before that I opened for Jeff Ross and I
wrote for 10 Comedy Central roasts and I
was on two seasons of roast battle and I
I professionally make fun of people is
the through line and meanwhile they saw
that and go yeah we're going to continue
with the story of right you know
disgusting and and ridiculous but that's
just the media now for clicks and for
whatever just want to see you know yeah
burn they just want to see victims and
trouble and bad and
speaking of burn
do we know what happened to Jay Leno
that was a [ __ ] pretty funny joke the
other night that was okay that was yeah
William Montgomery with the Jay Leno
roast joke like yeah but but uh yeah
that was [ __ ] up dude there was a
roast of Jay Leno yeah
but how bad was Jay Leno I mean that
happened the same day that I put up a
video about my horrific Burns
really yeah you were burned 15 of your
body yeah I mean he was Jay Leno was
burned a little bit what if every time
you put out that video another celebrity
this is the start of a really creepy
movie upload yeah
um
but yeah what what about it I mean I
didn't know I only heard that he got
burned was it bad or was it just
um I think that it was like a part of
his face was burned but that's it it
wasn't like he's [ __ ] 80 of his
bodies well his chin is a natural fire
Hood so it blocked most of that 15 of
the burns on his chin yeah yeah
um I think he's gonna be okay yeah no
doubt about it yeah but dude Burns her
and early man yeah I remember the most
painful oh yeah that's right I'm
supposed to do kill Tony when I got my
Burns yeah I remember yeah there was a
lot going on you have to you you
remember I used to be neighbors with
classic yeah and I remember man that
that stuff happened they were none too
pleased with you there later that
goddamn Steve almost [ __ ] killed
himself again
yeah that was that was rough that was
really really good Comedy Works and
and and uh we man was actually on the
the panel of kill Tony and and I was
supposed to be on there with him
and and uh
like it did start to picture how women
did on his on his own with that oh he
was good he was good uh
yeah no he's he's fantastic the energy
of all you guys and you know I just play
well with people that I respect that's
really the thing and like I said the
other day like jackass and South Park
are that's it like if I need to laugh
that's all I can count on or serious
stuff like I find you know Tarantino
movies and a lot of Scorsese movies to
be some of the funniest things that I
know of yeah and um but yeah I mean it's
not even fair like so like we man every
all everybody
that whole entire crew yeah I think
Johnny's the only one I've never like
worked with in any capacity but
um
but everybody else me and Tremaine were
in talks to uh we were like about to I
can't remember what happened we were
about to
do he loves kill Tony and we were yeah
we were very close to making some things
together and uh yeah super cool stuff
Rachel Wolfson yep yep Matt Edgar all
these people I saw Matt Edgar was uh in
on the panel forever to go into those
videos yup danger Aaron has been on the
panel uh
um
oh geez
uh oh my God you're not struggling to
come up with things
who on yes yes I am yes Chris Pontius
see that's where Pontius screwed himself
calling himself party boy or or chief
Roberts you know garbage man like it's
always some [ __ ] other name except
for his own goddamn name and then here
we are like scratch electric party boy
right uh yeah party boy what's his name
Bunny The Lifeguard bunny yeah like
every time you name one of these things
I picture it it's so interesting uh and
then there's
that like the guy the people who went
with the name that is not on their
driver's license
bam we man Steve-O right even Johnny
Knoxville like the the Absurd Goofy name
that's that sticks with the X it's easy
to remember served us very well and then
like the the guys who have the name on
their driver's license is the name that
they use
it doesn't stick as much I love it it's
amazing that new newest one was a
[ __ ] work of art by the way
incredible thank you I mean amazing
yeah you got you got a shirt from there
and I got a shirt from the movie I
didn't even realize that yeah oh wow
amazing
so cool yeah dude well thank you man
um so you're you've got December off
yeah just Dallas Texas and I have some
fun things coming up next year about to
release uh
a huge tour huge 32 city
um
big tour coming up in 2023 so it's going
to be really really fun dude check this
out I just finished a tour in Canada I
did 30 cities just in Canada Whoa man I
turned I turned more cities in Canada
than any other artist period this year
whoa did you do Lloydminster you bet I
did do you do Saskatoon a bad idea Red
Deer Dawson's Creek I did [ __ ] you'd
never even heard of dude Dawson Creek
Red Deer Medicine Hat
what size are these venues up there how
big was the venue in Medicine Hat
Medicine Hat was was pretty small I had
two shows there I added a show
in Dawson Creek the population of Dawson
Creek is 12 000. yeah I had 1300 at my
show I'm not kidding dude
wow yeah there's killer man
awesome Dawson's Creek the TV show named
after that I'm reasonably sure it is not
maybe the other way around yeah yeah
they started it after that but yeah I I
don't know but uh yeah I I had a wildly
successful candidate around man I'm
super stoked what do you like to do for
fun when you're out there on the road
I uh
travel with I remember I got a bus now I
got my editors on the bus like it's it's
you know what I get a kick out of is is
making video yeah you know like at the
moment I'm um working on a video with
Wee Man it is uh Stevo versus Wee Man
the skateboarding challenge to see who
can outskate each other because we've
got uh this collab skateboard where
we're all done up is heavy metal like
Glam rocker and uh so we've actually got
our Glam rocker costumes and and we're
making Escape video wearing it so like
while in Canada I rented two huge U-Haul
Cube trucks and a trailer and built
ramps all over them and skated it while
it was moving
that's so cool my favorite day of the
whole tour wow and then as then the day
I got home I had a ramp built over my
new Tesla and Tony Hawk drove it at me
and I jumped on it skated over it hell
yeah
that's the kind of [ __ ] I dig I love
that you doing you filming anything here
in Austin just just podcasts we got a
three podcast day today I love it next
time we have to coordinate something so
that you could shoot like some something
cool and local somebody can I don't know
do something with a tuba or there's the
music here is so crazy right there's got
to be something funny you could do a
good you know you get Gary
flesh flute up your ass
um like Waco's very close to here we
love the surf to the no not my thing I
don't I'm not good with anything on a
board skateboarding surfboarding uh
difficult it's very very bizarre
snowboard
I have strong hips I used to wrestle but
for some reason I I don't like being on
my side do you watch UFC fights like
obsessed obsessed obsessed yeah me too
you watch the prelims oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah no I I love it you do too oh my God
never specified incredible I can't
believe what happened with Izzy on
Saturday night right I can believe it
yeah I I can absolutely believe it but
it's just it's it's such a shame because
that first round he had totally yep
about 10 more seconds that that [ __ ] was
over we got Tim Kennedy on the podcast
next oh nice I love it I love [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I'm scared to even say that
out loud he's gonna choke me out
absolutely he's the man Austin has a lot
of crazy that's another one you know
what you should do next time is next
time you come here plan something with
Gordon Ryan you know who that is the
world champion BJJ of all
he's literally the so much better
at what he does than anybody else has
ever been at what they do the only
person that they compare him to when
they compete like he's not like Michael
Jordan at basketball he's not like tiger
at golf the only person they compare him
to is Joey chestnuts because he's
literally like three times better than
the next that's ever been yeah with the
the chilly chestnuts
when I think of you because I just can't
help my brain but I always try to think
like what would be something fun for you
to do right I'm sure you everybody
recommends that you probably get texts
in the middle of the night like Yo dude
you should [ __ ] shove a this up of
that or whatever but yeah you know what
one one thing that I think would be good
is uh you um you ever scrape the dry
skin off the bottom of your feet after
going through moist to dry like
sometimes I'll go golfing and you know
like afterwards your feet get dry and
you do a little scrub thing and then it
adds like parmesan cheese yeah have you
ever thought about snorting a line of
your own foot skin
[Applause]
not a bad that's minor you listen to
listen to what the [ __ ] can you even
talk about this on I don't know but but
minor that's minor yeah just wait like
the the entire cast of Jackass
uh jacks off onto a plate just to be
tasteful we we just have like a face cam
to see if they're fun their their
expression when they actually ejaculate
but that's it you just see the face and
then you've got a plate full of [ __ ]
which goes into the dehydrator and then
once it's dehydrated you can scrape up
the line and snort that
let me allow me to give you credit
publicly for uh being the one to suggest
that the condom of Chris Pontius has
come which I swallowed and then [ __ ] out
he said dude I told you I'd saved it
you're like salt swallow it again
[Laughter]
I swallowed the [ __ ] covered cum-filled
condom wait I suggest you suggested yeah
it's amazing in front of his dad I
swallowed it [ __ ]
oh my god well that only leaves one
thing to do do it again yeah I don't
know whatever happened to it I didn't
like I never I never found it again it
uh it's dissolved yeah I don't know it
didn't it did not make the wait it
didn't come out it's still in there it
I'm sure it did but it just I I didn't
catch it wow oh my God that's hysterical
and Pontius barfed uh involuntarily
watching you do it yeah it was so
it looked like he coughed you know
and then Preston ran out and
wiped it up
oh yeah God it's it's a fun it's a fun
life we live oh my God
it's just crazy the two different worlds
of Comedy I'm up there working on the
next roast that I'm doing right now and
trying to strategically look at words
and figure out how these puzzle pieces
match together to make a funny and then
I come down here and you're like so I
swallowed the condom again and I'm like
yeah
it's just brilliant yeah
true and then there's my next plan for
my next hour yeah which is double d tits
full of breast surgery
[Laughter]
I need to have the experience
I need to know what it's like
a mean greet oh my God that's so funny
dude yeah are you really gonna do it
yeah yeah are you gonna snort the [ __ ]
while you have kids
yeah everyone's got to come on my tits
oh my god dude
[Music]
oh [ __ ] so you're gonna get double D's
and then what's the plan you just keep
them for a while ah three months about
like a workshop it oh my God I got a
bunch of ideas and I got a bunch of
other [ __ ] I will have Tim Kennedy's
shoot off [ __ ] sniper rifle through
his time oh my god well I'm not bad that
I don't think is yeah yeah is quite as
funny as these
yeah guns used to be hilarious
oh man
yeah you could also do things like I
mean you could walk around with just
shorts in your tattoo I mean that's the
thing it's like I I I'm a heterosexual
man identifies as a male right like uh
yeah I should be allowed to have my
shirt off yeah those are your tits those
are your man tits you're a man you
identify as a man right sure his shirt
off is allowed yep you could even go
shirt off and then do the bicycle shorts
paint yeah and really just make
everybody wonder what the [ __ ] is going
on yeah yeah it's [ __ ]
so we're all very busy working on new
materials I love it yeah exactly okay I
got I got one more really [ __ ] up
power in me and then I'm not sure what's
gonna happen after that
wow well I'll be following it closely
I'm a big fan man I love what you do you
always have to to get to even like
there's sometimes I'm sitting behind
that table on kiltonia I'm like I can't
[ __ ] believe this is what is up like
I've watched you forever and you get to
you know have you on my show and give
positive feedback and put you in a
position to you know look good and you
know you book Tom on the podcast there
you know what I mean it's like this just
magical land of opportunity and to get
to do that to someone that you know
freaking 20 years ago I'm fresh out of
high school laughing at your stuff and
with all my buddies and you know so
thank you well thank you awesome times
my friend any uh you got your your
Instagram and [ __ ] yeah I'm I'm Tony
Hinchcliffe on everything Tony
hinchcliff.com for tour dates and
whatnot and uh yeah kill Tony's on
YouTube that's right every Monday at 8pm
a new episode episode comes out this
will have come out a couple days after
everybody put this out on Thursdays yep
killed Turner goes out on
uh Mondays Mondays so go listen to the
Tom Segura episode and you're gonna see
a surprise appearance by Stevo yeah yeah
well hey dude I love you and thank you
absolutely thank you guys
all right any concerns not at all good
dude you're so funny bro that [ __ ]
cracks me up this cold as [ __ ] over here
isn't it right now it's weird this weird
cold front just came in
and there you have it we drove that van
all the way to Austin Texas for that and
uh those were the three ones we got
there Tom Segura Tim Kennedy Tony
Hinchcliffe where are we going to take
the van to next well I'll tell you a
secret next comes Mr Zack ass we're
flying him out to join us in Texas on
tour and did I mention that
Dothan Alabama Little Rock Arkansas and
Albuquerque New Mexico are all getting
taped for my bucket list special woof
man those shows are going to be fire
thank you for sticking around